hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast advances in live cell imaging
I am Bob Woodard of lab roots an all be
your moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roads and
sponsored by leica microsystems micro
Microsystems is a world leader in
providing innovative microscopy camera
and software solutions for imaging and
analysis of macro micro and nano
structures for more information please
visit WWE can this webcast is designed
to be interactive and we encourage you
to participate during the event you can
submit questions and comments by typing
them into the Q&A box which can be found
by clicking on the green Q&A button in
the lower left of the presentation
window we'll try to answer as many
questions as we can also you can enlarge
the slide window by clicking on the
screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of this of the slide window
finally if you have any technical
problems viewing or hearing this event
please click on the support button at
the top right of the presentation window
or submit your questions using the Q&A
button I would now like to introduce
today's speakers dr. jonathan jones his
director and professor to school
molecular biosciences washington state
university and dr. jennifer Horner who
is the global product manager life
science division of life like the micro
systems please welcome me in please join
me i'm sorry in welcoming dr. Jones and
dr. Horner to today's event I will now
turn the presentation over to them
I wish to thank the organizers for
asking me to speak today the topic of my
presentation will be the movement of
skin cells and how matrix receptors and
their associated proteins regulate this
essential feature of wound healing and
cancer first let me thank the
individuals in my lab who performed the
studies I will be describing today I
wish to especially thank former lab
members Kevin Hamel and Christina
cliquez and to current lab members Susan
Hopkinson and show her eosin I would
also like to acknowledge the agency nie
arms at NIH to this funded our work over
many years and the dermatology
foundation for funding Kevin Hamel
during his stay in my lab over the last
few years the focus of this presentation
is on communication between cells and
their microenvironment this is essential
for development homeostasis and repair
of tissues our research in this area
focuses on those molecules which mediate
the interaction between epithelial cells
of the skin and the extracellular matrix
the topic of my talk today will settle
on the role of matrix matrix receptors
which belong to the integral family and
their associated proteins in the
motility of a kurata site that is a skin
cell that's found in the epidermal
region of the skin and we are interested
in this montilla T of these cells during
new closure as well as metastasis in
cancer work in the role of matrix
receptors in some utilities been well
studied by numerous groups groups
primarily the focus is being on adhesion
structures called forward contacts or
focal adhesions and their associated
actin cytoskeletal elements the
immunofluorescence image that i took
from the front cover of science magazine
shows a single fiber blast cells stained
with antibody get against a focal
adhesion protein in green and actin
cytoskeletal elements in red notice that
the red bundles of actin terminate on
green for contacts these termination
points appear yellow this is a very
simplified view of focal adhesion
structure indicating some
of its major components however I also
would like to point out that there are
over hundred proteins that have been
shown to associate with the focal
adhesion the focal adhesion not only
acts to tether the cytoskeleton to the
cell surface and tell the cell itself to
the extracellular matrix but is also a
hub of signaling from the matrix to the
cytoplasm and vice versa the current
notion for how focal adhesions regulate
motility summarized in the following
diagram that a chunk from a paper from
2007 at the leading funder moving over a
substrate a protein called called called
called filling severs actin filaments
comprising the actin cytoskeleton this
results in the formation of new actin
filament ends to which fresh protein
actin monomers associate the newly
formed polymers then facilitate self
extension and selfish fusion events
focal adhesions stabilized on
interaction with matrix and this allows
the Santa developed traction forces
these forces pull the backend of the
self forward in the detachment of the
backend of the cell in combination with
traction forces and acting for
memorization allows the cell to move in
a forward stir action the scheme I just
described is complicated in the south we
work on that is epidermal cells of the
skin since they possess not only these
focal adhesion structures that I just
mentioned but an additional matrix
attachment device term to Henry Dez's
own so let me spend a few moments
showing destruction molecular
composition of this thing whoo what the
Hemi does is on this schematic is of
intact skin showing the multi layers of
kurata sites in the epidermis these
layers of epidermal cells sit on a
connective tissue or dermis composed of
extracellular matrix fibroblasts immune
cells blood vessels glands and nerves
the electron micrograph that has now
appeared chosen me to wear an epidermal
cell or kurata site interacts with the
dermis before
open arrowheads mark electron-dense
structures and these are the Hemi des
hommes of the skin because of this
electron density appearance how many
desis ohms have been described as spot
wells that function in tact tissue to
interact the epidermal layer connective
tissue and this is consistent with what
we know about hamid asses of function as
i will describe next this unfortunate
baby has a disease called gentle
epidermolysis bullosa or je b for short
JEP babies lat formed Hemi lysosomes and
Annie electron microscopic view of a
cross-section to a blister of one of
these poor patients is shown towards the
right you can see an intact layer of
skin cells that has detached from the
underlying dermis this is because of the
lack of hemi gases ohms which are not
formed and therefore the epidermal cells
do not attach appropriately to the
basement membrane and the connective
tissue simple abrasion of these poor
children results in blister formation
because of the separation of the
epidermal cells from the underlying
connective tissue let's now look at the
molecular composition of the Hemi desert
song in this diagram I'm showing you all
of the known major components of the
Hemi desert song the first thing I
should point out is it is a somewhat
less complex structural entity to the
focal adhesion that I mentioned before i
go to talk about several different
protein components of the Hemi desert
song during this talk and i'm going to
mention these here so the plaque in
molecules at the top called BP a g1e and
platon these are involved in testing the
cytoskeleton to the cell surface I'll
mention be Phe only a number of times
during this talk I will also focus on
the transmembrane components of the Hemi
desert song namely alpha 6 beta 4
integrate and college and 17 alpha 6
beta Ford is a heterodimer composed of a
single alpha and beta subunit it is a
matrix receptor collagen sent
Jean is an atypical collagen it's a
tight to membrane protein that is its
panther membrane with its n-terminal in
the cytoplasm and has a large collagen
like extracellular domain it binds BP a
g1e and beta for integrin in the
cytoplasm and after six integrate and a
matrix molecule called lamb in 332 in
the extracellular space interestingly
lamb in 332 of access both a ligand for
collagen type 17 as well as integral
after six beta form so far I've
emphasized how many dozens ohms tether
cells down so what happens during skin
remodeling the results from wounds or
tumor Genesis so the first thing that
happens is to allow cells to move Hemi
desert somes in the undamaged epidermal
cells are disassembled this is well
established in the literature the dog
were then suggests that they only reform
when cells have closed the wound in fact
as I diagrammatically represent here the
literature would imply that focal
adhesions assembled at the front of the
cell moving over a substrate
predominating mechanisms that facilitate
wound closure but what about hameed
acids or proteins in motile cells my
object today is to convince you that
Hemi Desormeaux proteins are involved in
closure in an active fashion by
regulating both signaling and
structurally by regulating such as
skeletal dynamics I hope to show you
that they're not simply acting to
restrict the motility of even a moving
skins sound so what is the experimental
evidence for Hemi dancers on protein
involvement in motility first Hemi
lasers on proteins as I'll show you in a
few minutes localized to the right place
at the right time moreover Hemi dances
on protein deficient cells exhibit
aberrant motility not showing that soon
so first of all let's talk about the
wareham adesso swamps are are in
actively migrating cells so this image
set of images is of skin cells that were
grown to confluence in
drop the lawn of sounds was then wounded
using an arrow perpective the country
was then fed with meet him to activate
cleaning of the world the culture was
then fixed and saving about four to six
hours after this wording process at that
time the cells had actively might break
it into the wound created in vitro the
wound site is he indicated on the phase
image of the cells and at the left on
the right the fixed cells were then
stained to show beta for integral
localization to shown in red you can see
that beta Thor is concentrated at the
very front of the cells moving over the
wound site and should also add the labs
of Bill Carter and john olerude at the
University of Washington in Seattle have
also observed comparable localization of
beta for interpreting vivo in human skin
wound undergoing healing we repeated the
same in feature wound healing assay and
stained the migrating cells that were
moving into the wound site with beta for
integrin antibodies in combination with
antibodies against another hammy Dance
Ensemble protein when I mentioned
already called bph you renew these
proteins clearly co-localize at the
leading front of cells moving into a
wound site okay so what about Hemi does
hemi dazzles on property division cells
what they mount NC phenomenon so in this
study we use cells derived from a
patient lacking beta for intervene one
of these are for patients suffering jdb
these were kindly provided by Peter
marinkovic at Stanford University the
sounds were grown to confluence scratch
wounded as I described before and then
healing measured microscopically a time
zero with Walter keratinocytes and the
keratinocytes derived from the JDB beta
for integrated officiants that our
patient showed similar wounds by 48
hours normal cells have clearly covered
the wound site in vitro however the beta
for integrated efficient cells have
significantly slower in their migration
migration capacity and a slow in healing
gradually intro so to ensure that in
fact this was due to loss of data for
integral and nothing else the tap into
the cell since they've been cultured we
rescued the sounds by infecting them
with a virus incoming data for integrate
and in fact induced beta for
interpreting these beta for integrated
efficient cells in this graph I show you
that the wound healing closure of one
type cells jb cells and jellies are
seduced to express beta for integral the
beta for integrating rescue je b cells
migrate into the wound at the same rate
as well touched us indicating that beta
for integral is essential for me tuning
in result in these cells what about
other hameed assets or more proteins
we've also provided in a number of
papers experimental evidence that sells
deficient in either BP a g1e or collagen
17 a deficient in motility so let me use
the example of BP aging running first we
use shrna technology to derive BP a g1e
deficient cells so we called out several
are knocked down lines that had reduced
expansion with bph une so what I boxed
what I box here is an imminent lot that
was first broke with an antibody to be
Phe ready and then an antibody tram tour
and the extract was of the cells which
were expressing the shr RNA specific to
be Phe when you the Sri cloud lines
indicated cure-all show reduced
expression of BP 80 running and CN 2
which I'll show in a number of difficult
later on in the talk show a reduction of
about 72 to 74 percent in expression of
be creating running when compared with
parental cells sure I shall images of
parental cells HEK cells these are the
epidermal cells that are expressing
normal levels of BPA gee money and then
clone to which is the be Phe when a
deficient cell line the cells were
plated onto glass coverslips and then
lead by phase contrast microscopy the
first thing
notices his difference in size the
parental cells are much bigger and have
spread more efficiently onto the
substrate so we then investigates the
motility of both parental cells the
epidermal cells that were expressing
normal levels of BPA g1e and not
themselves those who use an expression
of bph e1e by taking images of cells
every two minutes from period of either
one to two hours I will now show two
videos the first is of a parental cell
while the second shows three clones are
between a bit clung to be Phe 1e
knockdown cells so this is the first
video this time-lapse movie shows a
fan-shaped keratinocyte moving over a
glass substrate the cell has a leading
edge composed of a single lamella podium
the next slide shows the BPA G when he
knocked down south the three cells in
this time-lapse movie are deficient in
the Hemi desmosomal protein BP a g1e the
cells move but stay in place they extend
multiple lamellipodia over their entire
surfaces so going back to the images the
still images of those two movies I show
we can actually derive so-called roast
plots with a mentality paths of multiple
cells in the population overlaid on each
other so the parental cells move as I've
said in straight lines you can see this
in the roast plot in sharp contrast BP
aging runny knockdown cells tend to move
in place as was shown in the movie and
do not migrate in straight lines we've
also generated collagen 17 knockdown
cells using the same shrna technology in
this slide I shall Rose part of the
motility trajectories of a wild-type
cell population versus the college and
17 deficient cells just like the BP a
g1e deficient cells the college
incentive
cells move in place during our analyses
of wild-type cells we notice that those
cells that were moving in a single
direction this is sometimes terms
village in the literature directed or
process emotion have a fan shape the
leading front consists of a very large
llamala punctual protrusion and shows
you the direction of migration of this
particular cell type as we saw in the
movie so fine shape cells are one of the
two major more for morphological forms
that we observe in a population of
wild-type cells the shapes are these of
the two forms are shown here by phase
contrast microscopy you can see that a
fan on fan-shaped cell possess its
multiple lamellipodia we've actually
quantified the numbers of cells
exhibiting a fan shape versus cells with
multiple lamellipodia and you can see
that in this normal cell population is a
significantly larger number of fan
shaped cells versus non fan shaped cells
at any one time we next followed the
fate of a fan-shaped normal keratinocyte
over time this series of images of such
a star was made over 50 minute period x
0 the cell is Spanish shaped and moving
to the left it encounters an object by
20 minutes is developed multan multiple
lamellipodia and is long longer fan
shaped by 40 minutes one sees that one
la mala paga seems to predominate and
the sound resumes a fan shape and begins
to move in a straight line back the way
it came so our data indicated karana
sites exhibit a fan shape when moving a
directed fashion such as possess a
single possess a single lamellipodia
when the cell changes direction each one
first stops develops multiple
lamellipodia and lose they for its fan
shape at some point one lamellipodia
seems to predominate the cell been
resumed the fan shape and then
carotenoid moves in a new direction
determines but in predominating
lamellipodia based on our analysis of
wild-type cells we then reviewed the
morphology says some of our Hemi desert
knockdown cells and in this instance I'm
showing data of college and 17 deficient
keratinocytes so what we noticed and
what our quantification showed is there
is a significant decrease in the number
of fan shaped cells in college and 17
deficient cell populations moreover we
could rescue this defect by forcing
expression of a truncated rescue
construct encoding a conscience sentence
fragment we also looked at the
persistence of fan of the few fan shaped
cells in our knockdown population and
what we notice it is that the
persistence of the fan-shaped is
significantly reduced in this app is
this rear fan shape knock down sound so
if I just focused on the consequences of
Hemi deserts on protein lockdown on cell
shape and motility this raises the
question as to how does beta for
integrin and its associated proteins at
vpag one E and collagen type 17 regulate
the mechanisms of motility one clue
comes from a paper from the Marui
kovitch lab they show the beta for
interment efficient cells exhibit low
rac1 activity rac1 is a small GT pas
which has long been known to be
intimately involved in cell motility
mechanisms our data support also support
a role for rack and mediating the
motility impacts of beta for inter pin
and its associated proteins so let me
show some of the data that indicates
this this is all published information
in this study we are so first of all we
can show that we we can risk rescue rack
activity in the je b beta fold into
grant efficient cells by inducing
expression of beta for interview here we
showing a rank activation a say in both
knockdown or the cells that efficient in
beta form but jay b cells as well as jay
b cells expressing beta for interviewing
protein in this study
we took proteins that Co precipitate
with beta for integral antibody process
them for western blotting and then
subjected the west of lot to western
blotting with antibodies against
potentially associated proteins so as
would be predicted and 46 integrand a
partner beta for integral is called
precipitate with beta for integrating
from extracts of normal keratinocytes
but what i want to show you that in
addition to alpha six rac1 co
precipitates with beta for indicating
that alpha 6 beta for integrate exists
complex with rac1 and actively migrating
keratinocytes of course this leads to
the question ok what does rac1 i
regulate inaccurately migrating
keratinocytes to make a long story short
in a series of papers first authored by
my a post-op christina klikiss we showed
that rack activates the slingshot
phosphatase and that induces
dephosphorylation of cold filling which
induces activation of consonant which
leads to acting remodeling so now we can
put together a model of what are the six
beta for integrity is doing in actively
migrating and keratinocytes so upon
negation with matrix alpha 6 beta for
interviewing activates rack which then
activates cofilin to induce actin
remodeling and protrusion IE lamela pod
formation and which is essential for the
directed migration of skin cells however
i should also emphasize that there is no
evidence that r is a direct association
between beta for integrated rack rather
in a series of publications our data
support but alpha six basic for intimate
mediated signaling requires a
scaffolding protein namely BP a g1e so
what's the evidence for this firstly the
ability of beta for integrative bring
down rack is significantly reduced in
different big b ph une deficient cells
as I shown here and indicate by this
asterisk you can see much reduced rac1
that precipitates with beta 4 in the
deficient cells
second-ranked activity is significantly
decreased relative to controls and be
Phe money knockdown cells moreover Co
feminist Authority phosphorylated that
means it's inactive in BPA to any
knockdown cells moreover indeed i have
got time today at today to tell you our
data also indicate that conscience 17 is
an essential link that brings be Phe
runny to office expects for integrand
complexes inactive migrating cells to
allow the signaling through rack to
occur so conclusions for this first part
of my presentation are that the plaque
in molecules molecule B Beijing running
in combination with content type 17 and
after six beta for a multifunctional in
an intact issue they stabilize epidermal
dermal adhesion without them you get the
blistering disease junctional
epidermolysis bullosa however bph you
and II collars and 17 and alpha 6 beta
for intimate play previously
unappreciated roles in migration our
data imply that they that the complex of
these proteins is required for signaling
to wrap one and co fill in such
signaling is an important regulator of
lamellipodia dynamics leading to
directed migration an essential aspect
of retailing and an important mechanism
underlying the dissemination of tumor
cells so the next video plays that
provides a pictorial representation of
what we think is occurring during
motility of the skin cell video please
following wounding of the skin cells at
the world margin begin to move into the
wound back in the leading cells
populating the wound alpha 6 beta 4
integrand messages are likely co
translated such that their protein
components can be targeted to the
leading edge of the cell alpha 6 beta 4
integrins then interacts with its
extracellular ligand and in the
cytoplasm recruits the BP antigens
namely collagen 17 and BP a g1e
BP 81 e is a scaffold for rac1 & Co
fillin which is responsible for
localized actin cytoskeleton remodeling
actin monomers add to the remodeled
active polymers and push the leading
edge or lamela podium forwards the Hemi
desmos own protein complexes also
stabilized the lamella podium this
process then repeats to facilitate
forwards L movement
so if I've presented mostly data that's
been already published but I want to
talk about what we recently submitted
for review the first question we've been
asking leads from our model 11 spectral
speculation in this model is a Tampa six
painful integr in and all the BP
antigens vpag one E and collagen type 17
may associate with the actin
cytoskeleton and moving cells so we have
localizations to support this
possibility in this set of images we
show chrome localization of a for
localization of a focal adhesion protein
paxillin which is shown in red acting
which is shown in white and collagen
type 17 in green in a fan-shaped control
keratinocyte look carefully at the
high-power view of the three images
which have been overlaid on each other
this shows actin bundles of the base of
the lamella podium of an other moving
sell one can clearly see content type 17
in green aligned along the white actin
filaments paxillin appears in stripes
perpendicular to the same actin bundles
cause this leads to the question how
dense conscience tempting show this
interaction with acting bundles so over
a decade ago we showed that collagen 17
buys acting in full and actin binding
proteins using to east to hybrid assays
but we didn't really understand at the
time what that meant for moving
keratinocytes so in this series of
images we demonstrate that a cannonball
co distributes with conscience sending
along actin bundles of the base level
lamellipodia this is best shown in the
high power acting in four in red and
collagen scenting in green coat
distribute along these actin bundles and
because they of the income distribution
they appear yellow in the overlay in
other words I can for likely mediates
the interaction of collagen 17 and hence
Hemi desert or more protein complexes
including alpha 6 beta for Integrative
acting the actin cytoskeleton
quite dynamic in moving cells skin cells
are no exception since we have observed
association of conscience entering with
acting we next assayed their relative
dynamics and lifestyles expressing tag
type molecules this still image shows
acting in red and collagen 17 in green
the video that I show next shows a movie
of the same cells this keratinocyte was
induced to express red tagged actin and
green tagged college and 17 cell was
then filmed as it moved over its
substrate at the leading edge one can
see extension of very fine fibers of
active into the developing lamella
podium actin bundles move towards the
back of the lamella podium where their
movement appears impeded once they
contact green puncta of collagen 17
molecules
so here I'm showing you some stills from
that movie that was just shown in this
higher power view the actin bundles are
shown and have been fallen for a period
of about 12 minutes what happens is once
they hit these complexes of heavy doses
of proteins which are in green and which
now show up as a box their movement is
impeded we NEX compared the dynamics of
actin bundles in live normal cells and
cells deficient in a hand in the Hemi
dancers or more protein collagen type 17
which we've previously described as
being associated with actin cytoskeleton
so there's a significantly increase in
an increase in acting bundle dynamics in
the knockdown cells so we've quantified
this increase in dynamics and it is
significant moreover it is actually
rescued by expressing the collagen
scenting fragment that have also
mentioned before so therefore this deep
increase in actin dynamics is due to the
loss of conscience enemy cells we also
assess the angle between the base of the
lamellar podium and the art of acting
bundles in both control and the
conscience 17 knock themselves in
knockdown cells beyond was significantly
reduced this isn't consistent with an
increase in bundle dynamics so to
reconcile all of these observations I've
just shown you we come up with a
following model as a skin cell moves
forward actin bundles generated an
animal a podium move backwards this
backwards movement is impeded by Hemi
decimal protein complexes primarily
collagen 17 however in the absence of
carleton 17 there is no impeding of the
active bundle are backwards movements
and has acting exhibits enhance enhance
dynamics the effects of college and 17
loss on acting dynamics that is next to
ask
the collagen 17 is involved in the
generation of those forces traction
forces needed to move yourself forward
that I mentioned early on in my talk let
me explain in this schematic the authors
have depicted the development of
traction forces forces developed by
contraction of the actin cytoskeleton on
adhesion sites in this instance focal
adhesions exert force on the substrate
that allows itself to move forward so
this schematic shows how traction forces
can be evaluated in cells in vitro to do
so sales are plated onto a pliable gel
into which the investigators
incorporated fluorescent beans and the
salad D is too and moves over this gel
the forces it exerts on the gel induce
movement in the beads an image is taken
of these cells following visualization
of the cell on the beads the cell is
removed and an image of the relaxed
state of the beads is taken then by
comparing the beads before an ad for
sale in removed we can generate force
Maps this is a quiver plot or a force
map of a fan-shaped keratinocyte and how
under and it depicts the forces this
keratinocyte is exerting on its subject
at one time point forces are represented
by arrows the colors of these arrows
represent the strength of the forces the
cell is moving in the direction of the
red arrow in this sound forces are
concentrated at one front cover
millefolium at this one time point we
can generate these force map it's maps
not only on individual cells and sand
cells at any one time point but of
epidermal cells moving over this
substrate as I will show you in the next
video the traction force is generated by
a keratinocyte moving over a gel
substrate are shown in this video the
cell itself is visualized by
differential interference contrast
microscopy DIC individual quiver plot
images were overlaid on the DIC images
and assembled into a video the
arrowheads depict the forces exerted by
the cell yellow forces are the highest
and appeared to move from one flank of
the cell to the other as it traverses
the gel as it approaches a cell it
begins to turn concomitantly it
generates multiple lamellipodia and
traction forces begin to be localized to
these areas
so these still images should show the
DIC images of the same style that was
shown in the video so what one can see
is that traction forces are moved from
one flag of the cell to the other as
indicated by these ere are red arrows in
other words the selkies to be moving
step by step over its substrate and we
depict this in the diagram shown in
panel see we've also compared attraction
force is exerted by normal and our
collagen 17 Hemi Desormeaux protein
deficient cells in the deficient cells
champion forces do not appear to move
from flag defiant but rather around and
be displayed at the cell surface this
these results leaders to this particular
model and I admit it very highly
speculative but at this point it fits
the data I've just described the model
incorporates both of functions or focal
adhesions and Henry dances on lon
protease and motility you will remember
that I demonstrated to the vocal contact
protein paxillin is enriched to the
flanks and alone on llamala podium so
let me take you step-by-step through the
model so instead one actin filament
bundles and arcs is stabilized by focal
adhesions of the flanks of the leading
edge backward movement of the actin arcs
caused by our contraction is inhibited
by hamid arizona protein complexes
enriched in constant time 17 Henry
desert zonal protein complex interact
with acting and therefore this allows a
symmetric out contraction leading to
asymmetric traction forces at any one
flank the attraction forces at one flag
indeed release of cell matrix adhesions
at that flag the seller is then allowed
to pivot on the attached rank and the
release front moves forward actin
filaments reattach it for gladiators at
the newly position plan this process
repeats at the opposing flank such that
the move then sell moves in a stepwise
fashion over it
straight so to conclude this second part
of my talk I hope I've convinced you
that Khan's incenting binds to actin
likely through acting in for incorrect
size Carlton 17 by doing so is then able
to stabilize at in arcs at the base of
the lamellipodia conscience 17 then
regulates directed migration through
both scaffolding signaling as well as
determining traction force localization
in a moving sound so what are we doing
next well today we focused on single
cell motility now in a wound healing
system cells move as a collective sheet
so we very interested in the impact of
what's happening to the sheet as a whole
when we induce disruption or deficiency
in these Hemi gases or proteins of
obviously there's a major story here
because what we would like to do
eventually it from a wound closure in
vivo using either molecular genetic
techniques or drug approaches said till
we can enhance how many dances or more
protein expression to enhance wound
closure in difficult to heal wounds such
as those that diabetics have so now
we're going to hand over to Jennifer
who's going to discuss like hemp
products
so thank you very much for your talk dr.
Jones I think we're very interesting to
to hear your research on wound healing
and cell movement and and on that
subject I would like to now give you a
little introduction and and some
specifics about using our like ID mi-8
inverted microscope for live cell
imaging so I'll start with a little bit
of information on the mi-8 itself so the
DMI eight is our newest inverted
research microscope and it's designed in
a way to be fully modular so here you
can see a few examples of different
setups of the DMI 8 and the the unique
thing about this microscope is that it
can you can mix and match modular and
motorized components as well as
accessories to really fit your needs and
your budget and at any time you can be
upgrades to this as well as your needs
change or your research change so it's a
really flexible and powerful tool for
your research and another interesting
point of the DMI 8 is that it had we
have kind of reimagined the fluorescence
axis of this and we call this the
infinity port and what this does is you
can see here in the in this schematic in
red you can see the infinity port axis
and this gives you direct access into
the fluorescence access without any
other lenses or a secondary decks
involved which gives you full
flexibility to add any kind of imaging
or fluorescence illumination that you
might need and you can as you can see
there's also two different access points
so so you have flexibility as far as how
you configure at this point two and one
of the four sort of normal fluorescence
what we have that you can add is what we
call the external fluorescence axis and
this door this couples directly to the
infinity port it gives you not only a
place to attach a liquid light guide so
for high-end imaging sources but also
gives you access to the field and the
aperture planes as well as it gives you
a place where you can put in things like
I'm fast filter wheels for for fast live
cell imaging and as you can see here
there are you can have
is located either at the back of the
microscope or I'm going to the left or
right side so depending on your
configuration or your your set of work
your space constraints do you have
flexibility there and so once you have
this fluorescence axis added you then
have the ability to add on things like
fast LED light engines so when you're
doing live cell imaging often you want
to image as fast as possible so you can
catch these these events as they happen
on your in your cells in real time so do
you need a combination of generally a
good light source but also when I can
switch colors very quickly if you're
doing multicolor for our sins as well as
well as some fast cameras which can
capture events as quickly as possible so
along with this this infinity port that
I just mentioned you also have multiple
access points for camera so you can
attach a fast camera that you might need
to do your imaging as well so then
getting into a little bit more specifics
of what you might need for live cell
imaging so imaging live cells over a
long time it can be a very tricky thing
so you I want to be sure that your
imaging only what's happening within
yourselves in the imaging process itself
is not affecting your cells on wherever
possible so some of the things you need
to think about are maintaining a warm
temperature so that your cells don't get
affected by temperature changes or shift
or changes in the gases so 0 2 or co2
typically have to be regulated and then
you want to have things like live cell
objectives which are dedicated towards
the type of imaging you're doing so
cells in media for instance and then
oftentimes you're doing imaging over a
long period of time over hours or four
even days so you want to be sure that
your cells stay in focus over time and
we have things like feet and like our
AFC unit which I'll explain in the
coming slides which hold your focus over
a long period of time and then finally
you need a software that can kind of
that can combine everything control it
and also analyze your data and for that
we have our Ellie OS x software so seen
here you can see there's a on this
particular setup of the DMA eight you
have a very large cell incubator here
which gives you the ability to control
your temperature and your and also the
patch to manipulate so you can open
doors and you can get
into yourselves if you need to prepare a
lot of other things you can add for your
environmental control and shown here are
just a few of the things you might want
to have so along with the large cell
incubator there are things like small
small incubators we're still on your
stage stuff which you can see here on
the left and then you need different
controllers and you can see here various
controllers from some some of our third
party partners that are actually been
integrated into our software so you can
can directly control the and monitor
what's happening in your in your
cellular environment as you're doing
your lifestyle imaging so you can really
be sure that what you conditions you you
think have are really what's in yourself
then if we move away from that from the
environmental control the next thing you
want to think about typically is your
imaging itself so your objectives and we
have several different and accessories
that can really help maintain the best
imaging quality possible first you can
see on the left hand side you see our
water immersion micro dispenser so this
is for water immersion objectives and it
maintained so if you're imaging over a
long time and if you have a 37-degree
environment for instance you have a lot
of evaporation on your on your objective
itself and this micro dispenser make
sure that that you don't have that but
you never that you depending on how long
you're doing your your imaging that you
always have your objective in water as
it's close to being the next thing in
the middle you can see is our mote core
objective so this is a motorized
correction collar which basically make
sure that you have the right refractive
index going on yourselves we have the
right correction for depending on
whether your experiment changes over
time maybe if temperature if you change
the temperature or you change the
substrate that's going on in there the
milk or can then be adjusted to maintain
the right refractive index there and
then the last thing you see on the right
hand side is a live cell objective so we
have some dedicated objectives and
specifically for design for live cell
imaging in this case you have versus 63
x 14 you whisper all core objective and
this is this gives you the best really
nice images under physiological
conditions so it's really designed to be
compatible with
I've sell conditions so once you have
your objectives that you need to make
sure that you have a focus you maintain
your focus throughout the length of your
experiment and for that we have a couple
of things to assist you the first is
called RAF see this stands for adaptive
focus control and this is an led-based
system which keeps your cells in focus
even if environmental conditions change
so if you add if you add a drug let's
say or if you add change or media
they're back to focus focus control can
adjust to those changes and the second
thing is that we have within our la sx
software there's a high speed auto focus
as well so if you combine the AFC and
the autofocus and you can really reduce
your phototoxicity that happens in cells
because we don't even reduce your focus
time and this can help with you when you
want to make sure that your cells are
getting the lowest level of light
possible while still maintaining a good
imaging and then finally the thing that
ties everything together is the software
and for that we have I mentioned a few
times our Ellie OS x software and this
is a nice thing about this software that
we've really made it work flow orient
kids so you can see whenever you're
doing your research setting up your
experiment you have a tab like this
which really walks you through the
different points of your analysis from
setting up from microscope itself
setting up your experimental conditions
and then and then processing your data
and all the way future analysis and in
addition similar to our DMI a microscope
the lal ASX software is very modular and
you can you can pick and choose which
modules are going to make the most sense
for your experiment so in this case I'm
showing a panel from our environmental
control module which you as you can see
here you can control you can control and
monitor the temperature as well as the
gases and you can really make sure that
your experiment is running as you would
like and then finally once you collect
your data you then need to make sense of
it for that we have several different
advanced analysis packages which can let
you do things from from the very simple
such as just cell calcium to very
advanced where you can add a lot of
different masks and you can do things
like deconvolution
and really get the or cell trafficking
different things so taken together with
the microscope and the software you
really can get all the all the
accessories you need to make sure that
you're you're putting you're setting
yourself up for the best experiment you
can when doing live cell imaging them so
with that I just want to again show you
our DM I ate and and encourage you all
to take a look at our website or talk to
your local sales rep and learn more
about this isn't are inverted microscope
and how it can help you with your
research so finally I just would like to
thank everyone for joining our webinar
today and I think we will be very happy
to take questions
thank you for that informative
presentation before we get started on
question and answer session I would like
to remind an odd our audience on how to
submit questions you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
queue a green button at the lower left
of the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can our
first question is do not skin at a
serial cells also expressed before
integrand and it and is it involved in
motility yeah this is jonathan jones
I'll answer that question so a number of
workers have looked at beta for integral
expression and its role in motility in
non skin cells such as breast epithelial
cells and other tumor cells and the work
of Arthur mercurio who i believe is
currently the university of
massachusetts suggested the batesville
incident is involved in motility knees
cancer cells and another question is are
the BP antigens important in other cell
types so the BP antigens include both
collagen 17 and PP a g1e collagen
Seventeen's role in other cell types and
other epithelial tissue types is a
little more difficult to ascertain
although it is present in glander
material and has been recognized as
being a component of lung epithelial
cells its role is not so clear in these
other cell types be Phe 1e however is a
member of a family of molecules which
are called the plaque ins and there are
isoforms of bph you any presents even in
Iran all tissues and the loss of bph
you won isoforms in neuronal systems as
shown by lane fixes lab leads to
neuronal deficits another question does
the like DMI 8.com with dark field
objective so I can take that question
and the answer is yes definitely so the
DMI a is capable of all of your standard
contrasting methods so bright field
darkfield polarization a DIC fame
contrast so yes dark field is definitely
one of the things that you can do with
DMI ain't absolutely okay we have
another question here for dr. Jones do
you quantify the fluorescence signals
you acquire from fluorescence imaging or
use it mainly for localizing the
proteins of interest that's an
interesting question and we are
developing methods to quantify
fluorescence signals but at the moment
we look primarily at where the proteins
are but I think it's very important as
we develop the technology and develop
the model systems that we actually
quantify using different methods to
specify where and how much the protein
is localizing wait wait localizes yes
that's a good question I have another
question where the quiver plots to
measure attraction forces generated
using the like a software I believe so
yes I think they were because we did
those measurements on the like sp8
confocal microscope
another question with which parameters
did you obtain the video one two and
four on the microscope software and
software um I need further clarification
of that question I'm not quite sure what
that question actually what what
parameters i'm not sure what parameters
means what the question of means by
parameters in that question i'll have
the table that one all right do we have
any more questions coming in from our
own it I think there was a question from
a colleague of mine called jeff Teague
who I know and he was asking whether
they were a number of file apology in
the movies a beta 4 and the Hemi dashes
all proteins in the file podia it looked
like they were yes we do sometimes see
the BP antigens localized over an
associated with acting in filopodia we
haven't really looked at that very
extensively we need to do further
analysis to confirm that localization
and it also goes on just as also asked
is Pakistan and also need structures or
different structures we do not see
overlap of the BP antigens and paxillin
so the Apache saline may be localized
and I can't remember whether we see
paxillin in the filopodia but they not
Co distributed all right give our
audience a moment to submit the more
question
you
right we have another question in from
our audience there were a number of
shrila protea in the movies are before
and the Hemi deaths and most cell
proteins in phila podia I think we
answer that question I answered oh you
did oh so I see it as marked an answer
so I see another question that comment
came in parameters magnification time
exposure time scale events Appetit
Archer and light intensity if they could
clarify the question a little more I
think the individual is asking what
magnification we use to generate the the
the movies I will have to get back to
you as a separate email to quote to get
that we generally take what i can say is
that we generally take movies over 12 to
our time periods with a an image taking
every one to two minutes to generate our
time-lapse movies but the time exposure
etc I'll have to get back to you all
right I think that is all for questions
today I would like to ask our speakers
if they have any more questions any more
comments that they'd like 30 * our
audience today but first I'd like to
thank our sponsor leica microsystems for
making today's educational webcast
possible today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
six months from the live date you will
receive an email from Roberts alerting
you when this webcast will be available
for replay we invite you to forward that
announcement to your colleagues who may
have missed it is live event seekers do
you have any more comments
I do
I think I saw a question that came
through which was asking about what's
the difference or whether the advantages
of a DM I ate versus an SP a confocal I
just quickly if it want to check for
those that are unaware explain the
difference so the DMI 8 is a wide field
microscope and the sta to the confocal
microscope so the difference so when
you're using confocal you're using a
pinhole of light to collect your images
and it's actually a system that is built
on top of the DMI eight so it's an
inning mode if you will that is quite
different from why field so wide field
takes an image of the entire field and
in a certain plane where confocal takes
a very small pinhole of light and in
this way they can confocal can remove a
lot of the out-of-focus light and the
advantage with wide field is often if
you're doing live cell imaging you can
image very quickly and sometimes you can
also you can reduce your phototoxicity
there but to learn more about confocal
and wide field i would encourage you to
go to our like a are like a website
where we have a section called science
lab and there you can really learn a lot
about the basics of different types of
imaging modalities that would be a great
place to get some more information and
then just finally I'd like to thank
everyone for attending today's webinar
thank you thank you very much and for
again we would like to thank like the
micro systems and you will receive a
email from Roberts informing you of a
on-demand presentation good bye bye